>>Evan Stade: All right.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Evan Stade and this is Dan Beam
and we're both software engineers on the Chrome
team.
We're based out of Google L.A. and we're here
today to talk to you about payments on the
web.
Now, this is something that we're very excited
to bring to you because getting user payment
information is a problem that's as old as
the Internet itself, so we're excited to talk
about a new technique we've got.
So what are we talking about today?
Well, first, we're proposing an extension
to a web standard called Autocomplete, and
secondly, we're going to show you the implementation
that we have going in Chrome, which is partially
a proof of concept and partially something
that we hope to launch sooner rather than
later.
So without further ado, I'm going to cut straight
to the chase and give you a demo of what we
have going on.
I'm a new user on this Web site.
This is a site that sells booze-related accessories.
I don't know how to even pronounce the name
of this site.
I've never been here.
But this looks kind of exciting.
I'm going to go after this Lasso wine holder
so I can capture all the wayward bottles of
wine that are trying to run away before I
can drink them.
[ Laughter ]
>>Evan Stade: I'll go to Checkout, and so
I'm hit with a page that's full of forms that
I have to fill in and it's all this data.
I don't really look forward to doing this.
I know it's going to happen when I go to buy
stuff on line.
I know you're not looking forward to watching
me type it in.
So instead of making you watch that, I'm going
to back out of here and instead show you how
life -- how easy life could be.
So I'm going to enable the new feature we've
got here, going to try Checkout again.
And this time, Chrome pops open this dialogue
on top of the Web page.
It's presenting this information that Chrome
knows about me because I've typed it in in
the past.
So far, nothing's happened but if I type in
my CVV right here, I then hit "Submit," this
information will be sent down to the merchant's
site.
As you can see, it's reciting it back to me.
And now their site's ready to put this card
number into its payment processor, as soon
as I hit "place order," and I'm done.
The order is placed.
Now, that was really easy.
That was great because I'm really lazy.
As you can see, I don't even like typing in
my own information when I'm buying something.
And then there's another example of me being
lazy on this slide.
So this is me commuting to work at the office
in beautiful Venice Beach, California.
I'm taking the bus.
[ Laughter ]
>>Evan Stade: And here is me.
So I'm being very efficient in this picture.
Or lazy.
However you want to look at it.
I'm getting maximal rewards for minimum effort.
This is something that makes me also very
keen on online shopping because online shopping
is very efficient compared to, you know, real-world
shopping.
I don't have to drive to the store.
I mean, L.A. usually is a swath of traffic.
The store is way over there.
I'm over here.
Once you get to the store, you have to find
the item, you have to wait in line at checkout,
it's a big hassle and it makes you feel very
emo.
But the one thing that's good about buying
stuff in the real world is it's very easy
to pay.
So as soon as you get to the front of the
checkout line, you hand over a big stack of
cash or you swipe a little piece of plastic,
and you're done.
It's something so easy, a baby can do.
[ Laughter ]
>>Evan Stade: But as we all know from personal
experience and from what I showed you a second
ago, it's not as easy on the Internet.
So here is an example where I went to a Web
page and I -- a merchant site.
I tried to buy something.
I've never been to this site before.
And when I'm going through checkout, there's
these four distinct steps that require interaction
and inputting information before I even get
to the confirmation page.
Now, this is a big hassle, and this is why
we're seeing users abandon items in their
shopping cart or this is at least one reason
why we see users abandon items in their shopping
cart upwards of 60% of the time when they're
going through e-commerce checkout.
Something like 14% of users, if you poll them,
will tell you that checkout complexity is
one of the limiting factors and why they don't
do more on line shopping.
And then, of course, you might have navigated
here on your mobile device, in which case
you see something like this.
You know, half your screen is taken up by
your keyboard, you're trying to type in addresses
and numbers and things that are not easy to
get exactly right on a small keyboard where
predictive text doesn't help so much, and
so the abandonment rate skyrockets up to around
97% on mobile.
So this is a huge lost opportunity, a huge
frontier, much room for improvement that we
think we can tackle.
And that's one of the main motivating factors
for what we're presenting today.
At the end of the day, you end up feeling
a lot like Fry as a user.
You just want the sites to take your money
and give you your goods and you don't care
how it's done, as long as it's secure.
So what are we doing about it?
Well, a few years ago, Chrome introduced a
form-filling feature called Chrome Autofill
and what that does is when you type in information
on one page, it will remember your information
and then you go to another page and it will
help you fill it in.
There's a couple of problems with that, though.
For one thing, it's tacked on top of the web,
so it doesn't have an easy time of matching
up the form fields from one page onto another.
Since every page looks different, it has to
figure out what kind of data was going into
this field and -- you know, on Site A and
match it up to which field on Site B should
get that same data.
Another problem is that Site A may not have
asked for all the same data so you haven't
typed it in yet, Chrome doesn't know that,
it can't fill it in on Site B.
And then there's cases like you saw on the
last slide where there's checkout flow that's
several steps long and you have to initiate
autofill over and over to get through it.
And while this is a good tool to have in your
belt as a user, and makes your life a good
deal easier, it doesn't help much for developers.
Developers are people, too, of course.
So, you know, they look something like this
when they're trying to come up with the perfect
checkout flow.
They have a lot to worry about.
They have to make sure the UI is intuitive
and friendly and not confusing.
And there's all kinds of research.
I mean, there's entire journals that talk
about user experience research that focuses
on how to improve your conversion rates in
the checkout flow.
So it's a hard problem.
And then you've got to worry about selling
internationally, if that's your market.
You know, the address information that a Slovakian
user, an Irish user, or a local user would
put in is all different.
In addition to that, no matter what you do,
how intuitive or friendly your UI is, there's
going to be typos when the user is putting
in new information, or if they moved, they
changed their address, they have a new credit
card, or he's going to make typos and so you
have to validate that input and every site
out there that is doing that, is reinventing
the wheel over and over.
It's a big hassle.
From where we stand, there's a lot of ways
to better it, both on the developer's side
and the user's side.
The user is typing in the same information
over and over, and so as a browser and as
a platform, we think we can make a big impact
and reduce the effort of everyone involved.
The only thing that we have to do is we have
to have collaboration from the page and the
user and they have to rely on the platform.
So here I am again.
In this case I'm here in the metaphorical
sense and I'm a web developer who is not exactly
getting a free ride but getting helped along
by RequestAutocomplete, which is the loose
name for the new spec that we're introducing
today.
So what's left in this presentation?
Well, first of all, I'll give you a little
bit more of an extended demo of what we've
got going on the desktop, so I should say
that all the demos you're seeing today are
live in Chrome.
They're not enabled for users but they're
behind the flag and if you have -- you know,
if you download the Chrome source and you
build it yourself, you can see all this in
action.
After which Dan's going to stand up and he's
going to tell you how to integrate it into
your site as a merchant, the smoke and mirrors
that's going on at the last site that we were
on in order to make this checkout experience
possible.
And he's going to tell you about all the features
that we were able to add onto our implementation
to improve the ecosystem, both adding layers
of security and convenience.
Some of these features might even blow you
away, as they did to Dan.
After which, you know, I promised that mobile
was one of the areas that we could make the
biggest impact, so I'll give you a demo on
the -- the implementation that we've been
working on so far concurrently on an Android
device here.
So without further ado, it's time to check
out.
I'm going to press this big juicy button and
this is the dialogue that you saw a few minutes
ago.
So one thing you didn't see before is this
big red banner on top.
The point of this banner is that this slide
deck, which is an HTML5 slide deck, is not
actually a secure place to input your credit
card information, so we're warning the user
about that.
But that's okay.
As the user, I'm going to make an executive
decision to input my information anyway.
Now, Chrome already has this information stored
about me.
I haven't had to type anything in.
But I'm actually going to say that I am shipping
this to my dog.
It's a gift.
So I'm changing the shipping details.
As you could see, it was really easy to choose
among the different addresses that Chrome
has remembered about me.
And something else I'll need to do, of course,
is type in my CVV, and here we go.
I'm going to press "Submit."
Like I mentioned before, input validation
is one of the things that we're targeting
for our implementation because, of course,
9I8 is not a valid CVV so we're trying to
make the experience really easy for users
to understand why the submission failed, give
helpful error messages, and make sure that
the data that we collect from users is real
high-quality before we send it down to the
merchant.
One last thing I'd like to point out is that
all of this is stored locally in Chrome but
this also syncs to the cloud.
At least the shipping addresses here are.
So I never typed in these addresses into this
particular Chromebook, but my other Chromebook,
which I've left at home, is where I typed
it in originally, and because I have Chrome
sync enabled, it synced to all my devices.
Anyway, I can press "Submit," it's done, and
I'll hand it over to Dan to tell you how to
get this nearly one-click experience on your
site.
>>Dan Beam: Hello, everyone.
So I'm sure you all are wondering how do I
integrate this with my site.
Well, at a developer conference everyone wants
to see some code, right?
So let's see some.
First, we're going to go through tweaking
your existing markup to allow RequestAutocomplete
to work with it, and then we're going to invoke
the API and handle some errors.
So here's an example of a typical web form
that you would see today.
Unfortunately, this isn't entirely clear to
Chrome the purpose of each input here.
It looks like billing because we have credit
card and CVV, but we also have inputs that
could be ambiguously for shipping or billing
addresses, right?
So in fact, it's not just unclear to Chrome,
it's unclear to all browsers because this
is a little underspecified.
So a while back, HTML5 added the Autocomplete
attribute to itself, which we then implemented
in Chrome for Chrome's form-filling, and then
we are piggybacking and reusing for RequestAutocomplete.
So if you want to invoke the API, you can
take one second and add Autocomplete to each
input name.
So as we expected, they're actually all billing
address inputs.
Great.
So now that we've elucidated each input's
purpose to Chrome so that we're more confident
about getting information from the user and
filling it back in correctly, how do we invoke
the API?
So it should be literally as easy as formelement.requestAutocomplete.
We've worked really hard to keep the API very
slim and easy to use.
Integration, super quick.
So don't start hacking away yet.
As a security -- as a security measure, we
only allow the API to be invoked in response
to a user gesture.
So we're going to show you an example of that
later, and first, we also have some ideas
how you could optimize RequestAutocomplete
for your flow, because while we were working
on this, we noticed that if you take the existing
web form flow we have here, and then you just
invoke RequestAutocomplete on top of it, you're
in double trouble, right?
You have a form on top of a form.
People will be forced to make exhibit names
about you.
No one wants that.
So instead, here's an alternate example, right?
So we recommend doing something along these
lines.
We recommend that you move invoking RequestAutocomplete
earlier in your checkout flow, right?
So in response to clicking on a "checkout"
button or maybe when you're adding new users
and asking billing information from them,
right?
So let's -- as you see, I've added a "checkout"
button here, and let's see a slightly beefier
code example.
So here we're using simple feature detection
to determine whether the user's browser has
requestAutoComplete.
So this will allow you to write code now that
should work in the future when all browsers
have this.
So if the browser does not have RequestAutocomplete,
we fall back simply to the traditional web
form flow, and if it does, we can simply unclick,
invoke our API, and then on successful submission
you'll get a brand-new event dispatching a
form called the Autocomplete event.
Don't feel bad, we just added it.
Don't feel left out, if you didn't know about
it.
And then after that, the form has all the
information filled in it and you can just
submit it normally like you usually would.
Okay?
So -- and then at this point, like I mentioned,
you don't want two forms in a row so we recommend
you just hide your current form so it doesn't
clutter up your site and make users think
they're going to have to input stuff.
Great.
So if you were paying close attention -- and
I hope you were -- you'll notice that we also
have a "cancel" button, right?
So what happens when a user cancels?
How do you handle that in the code?
So for this, we've also added another event
called the Autocomplete error event.
This event includes, as a property of the
event passed in, a reason.
Right?
So this reason, in this case, we can handle
it by just looking for the "cancel" string
that is equivalent to it.
So in this case, when you cancel an autodialog
of a site, there's probably not much you really
need to do.
The browser has already left the contact,
so the user is already on your site, still
there.
Nothing explicit should be required so it's
really we're just returning, in this example.
And then there's a couple other reasons why
you might get an error.
The first is maybe your form isn't actually
annotated with Autocomplete yet, so that's
more of a developer integration thing.
Or as well, a user could have explicitly disabled
this from settings, like Evan did earlier
before the demo, to show the fallback behavior.
And then there's a couple other edge cases
that I can talk to you afterwards about.
And then lastly, let's get into our implementation.
So I showed you how easy this is.
It should only take a second to integrate
it with your site, and let's see how Chrome
implements our specific proposed standard.
So one aspect that I think Chrome has kind
of in common with new user or guest checkouts
on merchant sites is that we also have new
installs.
So if someone has just first installed Chrome,
how do we get their payment information without
them ever having actually input it into Chrome?
So we noticed early on that there's a high
probability that they will be existing Google
users already, right?
So in this case, perhaps if the user is already
logged into Google, we can talk to the cloud
and the cloud will give us from on high maybe
they've paid for something on Android in the
in apps payment SDK on Google Play or with
the Google Wallet app, in which case, they've
already given their information to Wallet,
right?
So all of these -- all these clients already
harness Wallet information, so we just went
ahead and integrated RequestAutocomplete with
Google Wallet, right?
So this adds a second data source for users
to choose from, so you have both local form-filling
data in Chrome that's synced, like Evan mentioned,
as well as existing Google users as payment
information.
This is really powerful.
I should mention a couple things that you
probably already thought of.
This also allows users that have already paid
from any of these sources to pay for things
on your Web site right now.
That is really cool.
As well as when you add, for instance, a credit
card from Chrome, it will be instantly usable
on play or any other source that uses Google
Wallet because it's all using the same, like,
common secure vault.
Great.
So we've come to the presentation that makes
me the most excited.
Uncomfortably excited, if you will.
So this is my favorite feature as a user.
I want to tell everyone about it.
I want to tell my mom.
In fact, my mom's watching right now.
So, mom, I have something for you.
[ Laughter ]
>>Dan Beam: So a lot of people minimize the
amount of sites that they give their billing
information to, right?
This is to make sure that if one of them -- in
the unfortunate event that this site gets
hacked, that there are less targets to accidentally,
you know, give out their billing information,
right?
So, what we've done -- and a benefit of integrating
a RequestAutocomplete() with Wallet is we've
added a new feature that allows Wallet to
never, ever give away your real credit card.
These are called virtual one-time cards by
Google Wallet.
So what this allows is for each transaction,
you can give out a temporary special card
number that the vendor site uses to charge
your original card without ever having to
give out the real card number.
This is amazing.
This is changing the way that I shop online.
I mean, this is really cool.
So, I mean, this changes the way, for instance,
I shop because before I was willing to pay
extra money to buy from verified vendors or
to go on sites that already have my billing
information to minimize how many actually
have it.
This makes that much less of a deal.
So, you know, if your information does get
hacked, they only have payment information
that can't even be used anymore.
So this is awesome for the Web, awesome for
our users.
And we think this is a killer feature that
we've added.
In addition to that, using Google Wallet gets
us fraud detection for free, right?
So we interface with Google Wallet's fraud
detection engine.
Chrome is elevated.
Chrome has privileges that normal Web sites
don't have.
So we can pass along secondary information
with each transaction to help keep the user
safe and to make sure that the correct user
is using the correct account.
So, say an attempted fraudster tries to use
a different machine than you have traditionally
used to pay for something, we can detect that
right away and we can issue before the transaction
even can complete like a challenge, a challenge
to re-enter your verification code off your
credit card.
Or in the case this person is trying to do
something especially nasty, reauthenticate
with Google completely, right?
So this is another security layer we are adding
on by integrating with it requestAutocomplete().
Great.
Let's see a virtual card in action.
So here's the same Web site that Evan was
showing earlier.
It is just in an iframe inside this presentation.
Let's see.
What do we want to buy?
I will get an aerator because it is a little
stuffy on stage.
I need some air.
Let's show the checkout flow.
You'll notice here -- first, there is another
error.
It is not the same as before.
This one is the details we shared with googledrive.com.
That's the site hosting this iframe.
You will notice when an iframe hosts and invokes
this API, we actually prompt the user saying,
By the way, this is isn't coming from the
original site.
Anyways, let's sign in to use Google Wallet.
Just as an example user.
All right, great.
This is my credit card information as stored
in Google wallet.
You will see my totally real card number ends
with 1111.
Anyone that's ever tested credit card sites
knows that's not.
But, anyways, let's protect my fake cards,
too.
All right.
So I'm submitting.
We're talking with Wallet.
And very quickly we come back and, bam, there
is a brand-new virtual card waiting for me
on the vendor site.
Again, this is a card that's given for each
transaction, the special number, and it bills
the exact same card without having to give
it out.
That's awesome.
You will never have to give out your card
on the Web ever again.
That's pretty transformative.
All right.
Do we want to show our promised mobile demo?
>>Evan Stade: Indeed we do.
We told you mobile was a place where we can
make a big impact, so we will prove it to
you.
I will point out one more thing about this
before I switch away from it, which is that
this number, the site will still run it through
its normal payment processor back end.
It will not do so until I press "place order,"
which is a really lightweight API that we're
adding.
It is just one more way to get users' data
from them, but it uses the same back end as
the site's already had in place for its other
payment flows.
And now I will show it to you on the mobile
device as soon as I log in and switch over.
>>Dan Beam: They will see our supersecret
password.
>>Evan Stade: Yes.
I hope no one can read that quickly.
Anyway...
(Chuckles.)
This is the same site.
This is the mobile version of the site.
In the time that I was sitting in that chair
over there, I looked it up and learned that
it is actually pronounced the oenophilist,
if you were wondering.
If you learn nothing else today, that's a
good take-away.
At this time, I'm going to go on and I'm going
to buy the robot wine sheath because I'm on
Android and that seems the most appropriate.
I'm signed in as the same user.
I will just tell you.
Here I go through the checkout flow.
It got my information from Wallet.
I didn't have to type anything in.
It is good to go.
I'm already ready to press "submit."
But I'm actually going to instead make this
a gift again but this time to Dan.
He's done such a good job presenting today.
Feeling pretty good about this.
Chrome already knows his address.
I have typed it in in the past because I have
shipped him things before.
And so it is suggesting that I fill it in.
And I have done so.
It is as easy as that.
So now Dan is the shipping man.
It is still being billed to John Doe's credit
card.
I am John Doe.
And as soon as I press "submit," Wallet is
now taking this opportunity to generate the
one-time credit card and sending it onto the
page.
And as I also promised before, this UI is
still a little bit rough around the edges
so this is a bleeding-edge copy of the code
that we have here.
And it's done.
So this card number, once again, is not the
one that ends in a bunch of 1s.
It is a new credit card number, and I don't
have to worry about what happens if the oenophilist
one day is the target of an insidious hacker's
intentions.
I place my order and I'm done.
So as you can see, even though I filled in
some new data, sort of, there was a form field.
I didn't have to type anything.
You probably didn't see the keyboard -- well,
you didn't see me use the keyboard once except
to log onto the phone.
That was the closest thing.
So that was very exciting.
Now I actually see this as a platform that
I'm willing to buy stuff on.
I mean, mobile is growing tremendously as
a platform from which to browse the Web.
And now we think that this will help increase
-- will help commerce keep pace with e-commerce
in the same way as browsing the Web off a
mobile device has possibly, you know, kept
up with or even will one day surpass browsing
from a normal desktop device.
So with that, back to the slides.
This, as you can see, is Dan and me if you
want to reach out to one of us.
Here's some contact information.
And now we'd like to open the floor up for
some questions.
There's both -- so if anyone has a question
that's live, there's mics up here.
If anyone thinks of a question later, you
can send us an email at this address.
And then also we have some audience members
at home who maybe have questions on here.
Well, if they do, we'll see them.
>>Dan Beam: They may not.
>>Evan Stade: We will start with a live question.
>>Dan Beam: By the way, this is Cindy from
the Wallet side to help us answer questions.
>>Evan Stade: This is Cindy.
She has been helping coordinate with Wallet.
>>> Hi, Cindy.
>>Cindy Lobb: Hi.
Looks great.
Can't wait to use it.
Now, now, one-time transactions aren't the
only kind of transactions on commerce.
I want to sell a subscription to somebody.
If it is always automatically behind the scenes
giving a one-time credit card number, how
do I charge it again next month and the month
after that?
Is there some way to tell you guys, hey, this
is going to be a recurring billing event?
>>Cindy Lobb: Sure.
So we would consider that a single transaction.
So the user is saying, I want to do this 12
times with you.
So that would be a transaction.
That would be a supported use case.
>>Dan Beam: Yeah.
We have been thinking about this for a while.
>>> Okay.
>>Evan Stade: Yes, there is definitely support.
>>> So if I was the vendor and I was getting
one of these one-time things, would I learn
that it is a one-time and basically know not
to save it?
Or would I have to actually just kind of guess?
>>Evan Stade: Well, I think that our recommendation
is probably not to be saving this information
because one of the things that -- even if
it's -- even if you're not dealing with new
users but returning users, you know, when
you get a new credit card and then you go
and you visit all these sites that have independently
stored your credit card information, you would
have to update it many times.
So if you are using this UI, our recommendation
is probably that you don't store it and that
they will just update it and continue to use
this API for transferring their information
down to your site over and over.
>>> As a follow-up to that recurring billing,
well, you had said that this is going to be
a standard.
And so I would imagine, like, implementations
in other browsers wouldn't necessarily be
tied to Google Wallet.
And so it would be nice from, whether you
are doing a subscription or whatever -- especially
in the case of subscriptions, to have that
be transparent.
That one-time-use card really kind of breaks
everything because coming from other users
-- sorry, other browsers, we wouldn't necessarily
be getting a one-time-use card.
Or is that some kind of required piece of
the spec that they have to implement in some
other fashion?
>>Cindy Lobb: So the virtual cards are specific
to the Google Wallet implementation.
So when the other browser manufacturers implement
this and they are handing you normal credit
card -- like, the user's original credit card
number, it is business as usual.
And the same thing goes for the Google Wallet
virtual card.
Even though we are not recommending you store
the card, you can treat it just like any credit
card.
>>> So just to clarify, so on our side as,
say, the site owner side, when we go out to
hit that one-time-use card again, it will
go through?
>>Cindy Lobb: You follow the same processes
and rules you would to normally process a
transaction.
So there's a card number, an expiration date,
and a CVV.
Everything that normally happens on the payment
network occurs as normal.
>>> Okay.
So it sounds like the one-time-use card really
means that I'm the only vendor that has that
number.
It is not necessarily you can only charge
it once.
>>> Correct.
It is per transaction.
So, like, there is a lot of use cases.
Let's say you ship things in two shipments
and you charge the card twice as you ship
each product, that's supported.
>>> Okay, fantastic.
Thanks.
>>> Sort of to piggyback on the last question,
I was curious what efforts are being made
to reach out to the other browser vendors,
like Safari or Mozilla, especially since the
tie-in seems to be -- or the juice in this
is the tie-in with Google Wallet and with
Autocomplete() via Chrome Sync.
>>Evan Stade: Well, we have been talks with
other vendors.
And we have received some supportive messaging
from them.
Part of the reason why we are going ahead
with the implementation is because we want
to prove through testing with some trusted
partners, A/B testing, that this really does
increase conversion rates.
Once we've proven the value of it as a platform,
we expect the other browser vendors to jump
on board as well.
>>> Okay.
And can I ask if Safari is one of those vendors
or PayPal, in this case?
>>Evan Stade: I don't think we can -- come
and see me afterwards.
[ Laughter ]
>>> So one quick one, not quick.
The warning, is that on who this form is going
to versus on the form submit?
So if you are using Cyber Source or Stripe,
right, am I always going to get that warning
that it's not me who's actually going to get
where that form is going?
>>Dan Beam: Are you talking about the warning
coming from a different frame?
>>> Yeah.
>>Dan Beam: If you are invoking from Stripe,
it depends on how it happens.
But, generally, if you are invoking from a
different frame, you will have a warning.
But you can work to remove that warning.
And I can show you how afterwards.
>>> Okay, yeah, because we do Cyber Source,
for example.
>>Dan Beam: Yeah.
>>> And then on the one-time -- I'm short.
So from the user point of view, so, you know,
we tokenize and then basically charge later,
30 days later.
And there's, like, the CS issue if a kickstarter
or your pledge may fail, how does something
like -- how would CS be able to work with
someone on a one-time card?
Does the user actually know they have used
a one-time card?
So you know your pledge has failed.
What card did you use?
No, you didn't use that card?
>>Cindy Lobb: Sure.
>>> What card did I use, right?
>>Cindy Lobb: Yeah.
So, as they said multiple times during the
presentation, this is cutting edge UI.
We have -- we are in the process of refining
the UI to make it very obvious to the user
what is going on.
And, obviously, we talked about it multiple
times, that when they get to that review page,
they're going to look and be like, wait, that's
not my card.
We're prepared to handle that within the UI
in a graceful manner so that they'll understand
that.
And more than that, in Google wallet, we provide
them a transaction history so that they can
see what transactions they have done with
Google Wallet.
And we're working to educate them on how to
make that analogy.
And then even beyond that, we do provide merchant
support to Google Wallet merchants that might
need extra assistance aligning transactions.
>>> Yeah, it was a little bit more of a feedback
than question.
>>Cindy Lobb: Sure.
>>> Thanks.
>>> Another one-time card question.
I was just going to ask.
I'm from Africa.
Is this going to be available globally?
And will you be able to integrate other payment
types that are not necessarily cards?
>>> That's a great question.
Google Wallet right now is U.S. only.
So international support would be something
we would do in the future.
So when you're supporting this on international
sites, the users would be able to use the
Chrome data as their preferred choice.
>>Evan Stade: So I would like to point out
that right now Wallet is one of the data sources
that you may choose with our implementation.
The other one being local Chrome autofill
which will also sync to your other devices.
We don't have currently -- this is bleeding
edge.
We haven't launched it yet.
We don't have international support in our
UI currently, but that's something that we're
looking to add very soon.
And auto fill will still be usable -- I mean,
autofill -- Chrome Autofill does support the
international use case.
And then in order to support that for Wallet
as well will depend on Wallet rolling that
out, which will happen.
>>Dan Beam: Yeah, it will be --
>>Evan Stade: Yeah, it will happen.
Yes.
>>> This is basically about refunds, how to
handle that.
Either a full refund in case your customer
returns something or if I want to authorize
for a higher amount but just want to actually
book a lower amount.
>>Cindy Lobb: Business as usual.
Just do the same thing you do today.
>>> So nothing changes?
>>Cindy Lobb: Nothing changes.
>>> Okay.
What about other payment options?
Like, in this case we only saw everything
about credit card.
Is there any option to distinguish between
things like credit card, cash on delivery,
or other things?
>>Dan Beam: Between credit card and what?
>>Evan Stade: No, this depends on credit card
right now.
I mean, credit or debit, right?
There is no cash on delivery.
>>Cindy Lobb: Right now Wallet only supports
credit cards.
You would not be prohibited from using RequestAutocomplete()
on your site if you use alternative tenders
like gift cards.
You would just set up the workflow of your
checkout so the user can choose those before
they got into this flow.
>>Evan Stade: What I think Cindy is saying
is that you can launch this dialog -- the
plan is you will be able to get this the dialog
and get everything except for the credit card.
And then if you want to do except, I check
mark, like, "cash on delivery."
That would be handled outside of this API.
>>> Basically, we have to check that before.
It is in the form step.
And then in the next step, the second step,
when the user selected the payment method,
we will call your Autocomplete()?
>>Evan Stade: Yeah, this is a process that
we haven't optimized yet, but we are looking
to further refine the UI to make sure we handle
things like loyalty cards, gift cards, options
like that in an efficient and, you know -- have
a nice flow for that as well.
Thank you for the question.
>>Dan Beam: We should mention if you have
other further use cases, feel free to email
this email request.
>>Evan Stade: Like I said, this is -- you
know, this implementation is kind of testing
the waters and improving the concept.
So we do appreciate your feedback and look
forward to it for all the different use cases
that we would like to be able to support like
that one.
>>> So if this Autocomplete() is to become
a standard, it seems that you'd have to support
additional Wallet providers.
So are there any plans to talk with PayPal
or Stripe or anyone else?
>>Evan Stade: Yeah, we look forward to -- we
welcome collaboration from others.
The standard itself is completely agnostic
to the payment data provider.
The data source is not a payment processor
or anything.
But the standard and where you are getting
payment information from are completely disjointed.
So different browser vendors may choose to
implement different back ends.
But we are also open to talks and collaboration
with other sources, but we haven't gotten
there yet.
We chose to start with autofill because it's
what Chrome already has cooked into it and
Wallet because of the features that we talked
about today which we think add security and
convenience.
And we are looking forward to adding other
processors in there -- well, providers as
well in the future.
Thank you.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Hey, guys.
The one-time cards sound awesome.
Is there a way on my site to only accept those
and not accept autofill data so I never have
someone's real credit card?
>>Dan Beam: I encourage people to use Wallet
when using RequestAutocomplete().
Right now we don't have a lot of mechanisms
for talking to the dialog from the site.
We're investigating various things to be able
to embed, like, inputs or something like that,
to be able to talk to the dialog.
We're working on that.
But right now hopefully most people just see
the benefit of doing that themselves.
>>> Yeah, I was thinking just in terms if
I only had the one-time card, if that would
actually have some impact on me in terms of
being PCI compliant.
Maybe it would be less burden on me because
I'm actually not exposed because I'm not handling
real cards.
>>Dan Beam: I don't know how this affects
your PCI compliance.
>>> I know it probably doesn't immediately.
But I am thinking down the road.
That would be an awesome option to have.
>>Evan Stade: That is an interesting one.
Thank you.
We'll think about that.
>>> Hey.
So, sounds like really cool stuff.
I just want to make sure I understand it correctly.
So the one-time credit cards, it is a merchant-specific
credit card?
>>> It is a transaction-specific credit card.
If I visit your site three times and I make
three purchases, it will be three different
virtual card numbers.
>>> Cool.
And then Chrome autofill has been around forever.
Are those two standards completely converged
so that if you mark up your Web pages for
Autocomplete() for regular Chrome, that will
automatically work with this?
>>Dan Beam: Yes, so autofill has already implemented
those -- the standard already.
We are just kind of piggybacking on top that.
So Autofill will work with that.
It either just released recently or will be
in the near future.
That's a recent development, though.
But, yes, it will work.
>>Evan Stade: They do share the same data
source.
>>> Okay, cool.
>>Evan Stade: If you type in information into
this dialog and save it, that will also be
able to autofill to fill into other sites
that are not using our API.
>>> Cool.
And it used to be like, X-Autocomplete() and
now it is just Autocomplete().
Is that right?
>>Dan Beam: That's been removed.
>>> Okay, cool.
So it sounds like every webmaster in the world
should implement marking up their Web forms
with these Autocomplete() just because even
if they don't use Wallet or the payment solution
or anything else, Chrome will make the form
filling incredibly easy in a very low barrier
and every other browser has a real incentive
to implement that as well.
Is that --
>>Evan Stade: That is correct.
And those that also want to use this API only,
then it is really lightweight to just add
the RequestAutocomplete() column.
>>> Okay.
Just want to make sure I understand.
I am about to tell a bunch of webmasters,
"You guys should all do this it because it
is a really good idea."
I want to make sure I understand it first.
>>Dan Beam: Like you mentioned, browsers that
don't understand this seem to fall back.
So it is okay to do it now.
>>> Would you consider or is this already
part of the standard adding some sort of a
mechanism for developers to identify the underlying
credit card being used?
So some sort of token or completely opaque
hash or hmac or something like that?
The reason I'm thinking this is for abuse
prevention.
Certain systems depend on the credit cards
being the only verifiable piece of information.
And so if a user can show up and do 100 free
trials of something, then that abuse prevention
abuse mechanism goes away.
>>Cindy Lobb: That's good feedback.
That's definitely -- we're happy to hear it
and consider it.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>Evan Stade: Yeah, and -- also, feedback
like that can go to that email address.
>>> Yes, email us.
>>Evan Stade: That would be a lot easier for
us to follow up and make sure -- to track
you down and have good answers for you.
>>Dan Beam: Great.
It seems like we are about out of time.
I didn't see any questions on the --
>>Evan Stade: If anyone has a question that's
20 seconds or less --
>>Dan Beam: Go.
Oh, nobody.
>>Evan Stade: I will start you off?
What about one-time cards?
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Dan Beam: The question was again?
>>Evan Stade: I think the question was do
one-time cards have a time limit before they
expire?
And if you want to charge it after that time
limit is over --
(Speaker off microphone.)
>>Cindy Lobb: The expiration on the credit
card is -- the question was for everyone streaming
live, what about expiration dates on the credit
card if you do an auth and then it expires
before you can capture the funds?
The expiration date is set up as such to give
you enough time to do that.
So that would not be an issue.
>>> All right, thanks.
>>Dan Beam: All right.
I think we're over.
>>Evan Stade: Yes, we're done, over even.
>>> Thank you.
>>Evan Stade: Thank you very much for being
here.
>>Dan Beam: Thank you.
[ Applause ]